dès le 8 novembre les démarches pour
demander une carte d'identité vont être
simplifiées pour les yvelinois les
habitants pourront faire leurs prêts
demande en ligne sur internet plus
besoin de se rendre exclusivement auprès
de la mairie de sa ville mais de remplir
le formulaire papier la demande de la
carte d'identité maintenant effectuer
selon les mêmes modalités que le
passeport après votre pré demande il
faut vous rendre pour un rendez vous
dans l'une des 34 mairies équipées du
dispositif de prise d'empreintes et
donner les pièces justificatives
le département des yvelines est le
premier à expérimenter ces mesures on
écoute julien charle c'est le secrétaire
général de la préfecture des yvelines
au micro de camille lambert pour
l'usager ce sera donc à la fois plus
simple plus sécurisé aussi parce que ça
permettra pour nous de lutter plus
efficacement contre la fraude
et puis bien sûr plus rapide pour les
services des mairies comme pour les
services de la préfecture c'est un
processus plus simple parce qu'il y aura
une seule manière d'instruire les
demandes ce que soit la carte d'identité
que ce soit les passeports ça se fera
d'une seule et même façon nous allons
donc lancer la procédure sur les cartes
d'identité les passeports mais nous
allons aussi travailler sur les permis
de conduire travailler sur les cartes
grises de façon qu'à la fin de l'année
2017 et bien l'ensemble de ces titres
soient délivrés de façon plus rapide
plus simple et plus fiables